hello my name is brooke lochren and i'm
joined by my colleague brianna goodwin
to introduce a series of talks
showcasing health equity access and
resilience collaborations
before we highlight what's in store for
the talks brianna i thought you could
share a little bit about why you came to
microsoft research to apply your skills
as a data science researcher to
dismantling barriers to health equity in
the us and around the world of course
brooke so as you probably know the cdc
estimates that about 60 percent of a
person's health is predicted by these
social determinants of health or sdoh
factors these are factors which are
often outside of a person's control but
influence their health outcomes
and after working in a clinical setting
both at seattle children's hospital and
the mayo clinic i've come to really see
firsthand how important it is to have
these sdoh data available in an
interoperable format and could really
connect them with the clinical data so
that way we can generate these insights
for lasting
change and really impactful impactful
change as well so as a researcher the
reasons for health equity are so clear
when we look at the published estimates
of diagnosed diabetes kidney transplants
and maternal mortality just to name a
few
one of the reasons i was so excited to
join microsoft research was the process
we used to deeply engage with our
partners
and the communities that they served as
as was just described in the last panel
as these boots on the ground
so i'm really excited to be here to be a
part of microsoft and to really engage
deeply with our partners to really learn
from and learn with them as we go
forward
well thanks brianna really well said and
i completely agree with you there's no
doubt in my mind that increasing
meaningful access to quality care would
deliver massive social and economic
benefits for the world there was a
recent study that i saw from mckinsey
prescription for progress that
that showed that
in the next 20 years we could reduce the
global burden of disease by 40 percent
just by applying known interventions in
broader segments of populations and also
by by applying the best known tools and
technologies available and new
innovations many which we heard about
yesterday in the discovery track could
reduce that burden even further which is
really exciting
but of course we know that we need to
bring researchers and innovators
together with communities like you said
that understand the local instantiations
of these opportunities and challenges
and so at microsoft research we're so
fortunate to be able to work with an
inspired coalition of partners and
collaborators all across the global
public health ecosystem to really drive
meaningful lasting change like you said
well
now brianna let's turn our attention uh
to the talks highlighting emerging
research and researchers that we have in
store for our audience today
so in our first talk we'll hear from cj
park one of our summer phd interns from
the university of washington and his
mentor dan mcduff a leading researcher
on designing hardware and algorithms for
sensing human behavior at scale on their
work to develop new methods that
leverage ubiquitous sensors to measure
physiological signals
their work could make it much more
accessible and affordable for
individuals and their caregivers and
care providers to obtain objective
health measurements in remote care and
other care scenarios
in the second talk we'll hear from
patricia moshki brodsky a consulting
researcher from the london school of
hygiene and tropical medicine and bill
tease a leading researcher in the field
of ict for development and human
computer interaction on their work with
our partners the global fund and the
stop tb partnership to better understand
digital health systems across 13 low and
middle income countries
this work to better understand the
technologies used in the tb cascade of
care and to identify opportunities to
share knowledge and tools is already
being leveraged by governments funding
agencies and implementing partners
around the world which is really
exciting
now let's hear a little bit from brianna
about what else we have in store
in our third talk i'm looking forward to
hearing from kartik bot one of our
summer phd interns from georgia tech and
his mentor mandy hall from our medical
experiences and design team about the
pivotal role that family caregivers play
in care provision and management
their research set in urban india draws
from interviews with family caregivers
to provide a deeper understanding of
their responsibilities the implications
of remote care on care management
and of the case of technology-mediated
caregiving and caregiver focused
interventions
and finally in our last but definitely
not least talk we'll hear from rich
carwana from microsoft research and
vanessa polk from microsoft health and
life sciences
rich and vanessa will dive into examples
of bias and machine learning models to
demonstrate inequities we see in
healthcare data and what we can do about
them
i hope you'll walk away with a better
sense of how interpretable machine
learning methods can be used to better
answer the links between sdoh and
demographic features and disparities in
health outcomes
i can't wait for these four talks
showcasing a small slice of the
collaborations that inform our efforts
to drive collective impact in addressing
health equity access and resilience so
without further ado let's hand it over
to cj and dan to dive into our first
talk
thanks brook and brianna
and welcome to this lightning talk on
increasing access to health measurement
through mobile sensing
i'll be presenting with cj park from the
university of washington
over the past two years many things have
changed in the world
and nowhere has this felt more acute
than in healthcare
the covid19 pandemic has rapidly changed
the way that people are seeking care and
increase the numbers of remote
appointments and visits
this is
partially to protect healthcare workers
and also protect patients from
becoming sick but also remote care
provides several other benefits it can
reduce travel time and also make care
more accessible accessible for people in
remote locations
and
in lower income settings
tele health platforms are becoming more
popular and they have seen explosive
growth over the past few years
but there still are several challenges
associated with remote care
how do clinicians
get objective measurement of the state
of patients beyond what they can get
from conversations
in this presentation we'll be focusing
on some of our research looking at ways
to make
applications of remote vital sign
measurement more accessible and this
technology could have applications in in
many areas
including telehealth but also in
neo-natal
sensing in chronic disease management
elder care and in global health
management generally
the types of vital signs that we have
been focusing on measuring
are primarily cardiopulmonary so this
involves measuring functioning of the
heart including the heart rate heart
rate variability
and functioning of the lungs including
respiration rate blood oxygenation level
future work is looking at measuring uh
more indicative vital signs that that
capture
more serious health conditions for
instance atrial fibrillation which is
linked to increased risk of stroke and
also blood pressure which is a key
metric um for helping manage
hypertension and many other
cardiovascular diseases
uh we're also interested in expanding
the the range of sensing beyond these to
capture things like body temperature
which of course is very important
in in the current world when people may
have fevers being a key symptom of
illness
and also things like glucose and
hydration monitoring which can be
important for
conditions such as diabetes
so in the remainder of the presentation
cj is going to be talking
about some of the work we've been doing
looking at blood pressure monitoring so
i'll pass over to cj now
hello my name is cj and today i will
talk about our work on mobile-based
copless blood pressure monitoring and
here we want to focus on the blood
pressure and hypertension
because it's highly prevalent and needs
consistent monitoring
and to give a little bit background on
the blood pressure
blood pressure is defined as a pressure
of blood exerted against the wall of the
blood vessels
and there are two types of blood
pressure
one of them is systolic blood pressure
that's measured when the heart pumps out
the blood and diastolic blood pressure
is measured when the heart relaxes
and in general if a person has 140 of
systolic blood pressure and
90 of diastolic blood pressure they're
considered to have high blood pressure
or hypertension and it's a major
cause of heart attack stroke and heart
failure and over 1 billion people
globally has hypertension
and it's even more prevalent in low and
mid income settings
where
in
urban india more than 30 percent of
population has hypertension and on 17.5
of all deaths
in india is related to the blood
pressure
so there are two common ways to manage
hypertension one of them is to take
prescribed medication
and another one is to
change their um diet and behaviors
healthier so for example
more exercises less alcohol consumption
and
have less
sodium and
saturated fat
and to check the effectiveness of
management and treatment blood pressure
should be frequently measured and
monitored
people often
have high blood pressure when measured
in doctor's office because of
because it's measured in unnaturalistic
settings so it is important to measure
outside of clinic to capture the true
blood pressure of a patient
and
hypertension has no symptoms so you um
unless you actually look at the numb
blood pressure values you don't know
whether you have hypertension or not
so
to help
people measure blood pressure outside of
clinics there are blood pressure monitor
for home use but these are often bulky
and a bit cumbersome to use and they
cost around 50 of us dollars and it puts
additional economic burden to people
who are in low and mid income settings
so the barrier to a better
blood pressure more frequently still
exists
in this project we think a smartphone is
a potential solution
as we all know smartphone is already
widely used by many people
and we witness increasing number of
smartphone users in low and mid income
settings as well
and smartphones are mobile and portable
has potential for more frequent blood
pressure measurement and also is
suitable for measuring blood pressure in
ambulatory settings
and
the smartphone
is
equipped with a diverse set of sensors
such as camera and microphone and motion
sensors which can be
leveraged to
extract vital signals
from the users
for example uh photoplasty tomography
ppg signal can be
measured using smartphone camera and
external light source such as camera
screen light and the flash
so when the finger is lightened up with
the um light source
camera can detect the change in color
due to the um volume changes
just like an optical ppg sensor camera
can produce high quality ppg
ppg signal as shown in the bottom right
graph
and in our project we want to pay more
attention to the shape of the ppg
waveform which can be available from the
smartphone camera
a previous
medical literature has found that the
shape of ppg
changes due to the blood pressure
and the difference in shape mainly due
is mainly due to the stiffness of the
arteries uh that affects the rate of
change in artery size when the
blood travels
so in our uh project uh to learn the
change in morphology of ppg due to the
blood pressure
we use convolutional neural network
it consists of one convolutional block
in the front and four residual blocks in
the middle and one fully connected dense
layer in the last
and the model has been used for ecg
classification tasks
and since the ppg signal is also one
dimensional time series data we expect
the cnn architecture is able to extract
meaningful features from ppg signal
for dataset we use dataset that was
collected by researchers at
microsoft research health futures
they recruited 1 000 participants and
collected various physiological signals
including ppg ecg tonometer and
accelerometer data
also gold standard blood pressure
measurements were collected at the same
time
and participants were asked to do
different body postures such as sitting
down lying down on a bed and standing up
and the data collection
were
data collection took place in two
different days
to capture the day-to-day change in
blood pressure
uh for
the blood pressure prediction
task
we define our task to be estimating the
change in blood pressure from the
baseline
so the input of input would have the two
one-dimensional ppg signals one from
baseline blood pressure and the another
from target
target blood pressure and then we stack
these two waveforms in
on two different channels and fit into
the cnn architecture
the change in blood pressure will be the
output of the model
and also we use the handcrafted features
extracted from ppg signals such as heart
rate heart rate variability
dpdt and the radial pulse arrival time
and also the demographic features such
as age and bmi
for training the model uh we split the
data set across different participants
which means that the 70 percent of
participants data will be
including included in a train set and
the um 15
will be used for validation and the last
15 will be used for testing
in this way the model is tested on the
participants data that it has never seen
during the training
so the first two columns shows the
baseline models that uses that use on
demographic features and ppg related
extracted features
and the rest of the column shows the
accuracy of our cnn approach
and the best performing cnn model
uses all of the ppg signal
demographic and extracted features and
shows
negative 0.6 of bias and 9.3 of standard
deviation
and it shows better
performance from the baseline reach
regression models
in the first two columns
however um given that the fda standards
for blood pressure cuff is
less than five for bias and eight for
standard deviation
this model still needs some improvement
next we change the data split method to
include a portion of each participant's
data during training and test on the
rest of the data
so for training set
the
initial fidget data of each participants
are included and the validation and test
set on the return visit date
of all the participants are included
the best performing model shows
0.65 of bias and 7.36 of standard
deviation which is just within the fda
centers requirement
however
this model requires a portion of each
participant's data for training
in actual use case people need to
provide their ppg signals and blood
pressure for calibration
so in summary in this project we
leverage signals available
from smartphone to estimate blood
pressure
we specifically look at
use ppg signals from smartphone camera
and we build a new
convolutional neural network
architecture using
that uses ppg signal
and as a result estimating a change in
blood pressure shows a reasonable
accuracy and exposing each
participant's data during training
further improves the accuracy
this implies that the
user might need to provide their
baseline and calibration signal for
accurate blood pressure measurement
as a future work of we're planning to
validate the model on the signals that
we actually we collected from the um
smartphone across different uh
participants
and uh that's the end of my presentation
and thanks for
listening now bill and patricia are
going to
present their work
hi
my name is bill tees and it's my
pleasure to introduce this talk today
i'm a researcher at microsoft research
usually based in bangalore in india and
in that lab we do a lot of work at the
intersection of technology and public
health where we often take a
user-centered design approach and work
closely with local organizations to find
new innovations that we can actually
deploy and evaluate together in the
field
some of those solutions have went to
nationwide scale including in
tuberculosis where we had a new approach
to helping support patient adherence to
medication that's now used in india's tb
program and other tb programs around the
world
in that process we developed some strong
relationships with the top global
organizations working in tb including
the global fund and the stop tv
partnership and what we'll tell you
about today is an exciting collaboration
between all of our organizations to
collaboratively understand what are the
barriers facing
all the countries you know that we work
in uh as they develop digital health
systems and how can we help them
you know develop those systems better
there's a exciting chance where we
actually got to go and interview some
heads of national tuberculosis programs
and the organizations that support them
to see what those opportunities are
our speaker today is patricia moskowski
she is a research consultant at
microsoft where she's led this study and
also works with the global health access
team on user and market research to
figure out where we should focus our
attention for the next set of
innovations in technology and public
health in parallel she's also a phd
candidate at the london school of
hygiene and tropical medicine where she
focuses on technology in national health
systems so without further ado i'll hand
it over to patty
thanks bill so much for the introduction
i really appreciate it so as bill
mentioned uh we looked through the study
to explore national digital health
systems and we used uh tuberculosis as a
case study um you know tb is one of the
the biggest infectious disease killers
um and has raised a lot of global
attention we thought it was a good
representative to better understand you
know how cases are managed that could be
applied to thereafter diseases and other
programs
per the who
tb program
strengthening case-based digital systems
is a top priority across countries and
yet despite strategic plans for
technology within each country it
remains quite difficult to understand
how to coordinate across countries you
know better understand not only the
technology landscape but also share best
practices and lessons learned between
different uh contexts as well as
understand the existing gaps that could
guide future global investments
so as you can hear from the graph on the
slide you know tb is spread quite thin
across different contexts therefore
finding ways to
share lessons learned
would benefit multiple geographies and
it is certainly warranted as a case
study
so as part of this study we focused on
high tb burden countries
and focused solely on tb technologies so
ict
tools were specified by cast tb cascade
of care which i'll focus on in just a
moment
the study consisted of
in
interviews remote interviews with 44
stakeholders
coming from representatives of
government from implementing partners
and funders
these were all conducted remotely and
we use qualitative research methods to
analyze our data
moving on to the results of the study
so as i mentioned to identify existing
ict tools used in programs we use this
tb cascade of care to facilitate
dialogue with the participants
the cascade focus on these four major
stages
screen diagnose treat and report
when scoping out the digital tools
we recognized that there was a major
theme
relevant to the different countries and
this is what we have come up to call as
a backbone so a system that basically
manages the entire lifeline of the
cascade of care
and it's usually implemented in one of
two ways so the first configuration is
when there is a combined case management
and aggregate reporting tool and then a
separate um configuration where these
are separate systems but they're somehow
linked
the most interesting you know aspect
noted is that there is
you know there are stages of the the
continuum of care
that may not currently feed into this
backbone
but there are and there are also other
segments that are not digitized at all
in which case there is required for a
manual input
when we um
examined all the data we really wanted
to understand you know this question
here how to nurture and evolve to an
ideal system uh when we were exploring
this area we we came up with four
different themes or areas that are
critical um you know the the technical
building blocks the digital architecture
itself as well as how technology relates
to people and the larger ecosystem
so starting with um infrastructure the
the technical building blocks it is
important to highlight that you know
infrastructure elements are a um such as
connectivity and access to devices are a
critical component and sure should
certainly uh be prioritized when
considering how to mature to a digital
mature system
um you know for for this graph right
here we can see that there is a
variability across different contexts in
terms of
access to devices but also people using
the internet and so interesting through
our interviews participants were able to
share various different management
approaches that they have used to cope
with infrastructure limitations so one
of which is you know creating online and
offline modes of the various different
digital platforms whereby
this allows to recording information
when there is poor connectivity in
certain areas
and then also the development of mobile
versions of digital platforms so when
there is a remote area where internet is
particularly difficult but mobile
data is accessible they can use that
finally you know
some
contacts have employed
their district level coordinators and
equipped them with tablets so that they
can go into the field and record data in
each facility on a monthly basis
with increasing you know digitization
in in a lot of these countries data
hosting and maintaining has also
received a lot of
concern but also attention you know
specific challenges related to physical
in-country servers being unable to
handle high peak data utilization um as
well as the cloud hosting capabilities
not yet being attainable within a lot of
these country borders
other mixed concerns you know relate to
policy considerations policy mandates of
having the data being stored in country
borders
and vendors and partners also storing
data on their own um you know on their
own servers so i i would say there's
this general uneasiness of having
cloud servers and the suspicion of
having these outside of country borders
so most countries you know have either
adopted
an in-country physical server or any
country cloud server however some hybrid
approaches have come up
you know these have been adapted in
various different settings so in kenya
there is an in-country cloud server
which hosts data but there's also a
mirrored server
cloud server in south africa in case of
any failures
similarly a hybrid approach seen in
indonesia is whereby a physical server
is used for data storage but then a
in-country cloud server is used for
actually serving users in the country
so the next kind of critical step to
examine is the digital architecture
participants shared you know various
different challenges with the very the
current digital art architecture
embedded in their in their countries one
example being the existence of these
parallel systems so a country informant
shared that in their country's
experience having two different systems
for drug resistant and drug susceptible
tb has certainly led to a lot of
inefficiencies
similarly a big challenge seen across
all 13 countries has been the ad hoc
usage of excel so countries basically
transfer their data into excel to clean
and validate the data and then they
transcribe that back again into these
digital platforms the use of you know
these multiple parallel systems
certainly leads to a lot of
inefficiencies and an inadequate
inadequate use of the digital
architecture
other examples of bad or incomplete data
where data is not the same as it is in
the um
in the paper-based records or multiple
entries being created
and then lastly you know data being
stuck in one system and not being also
transcribed or being linked to the
backbone or the overall holistic system
in the country
so this certainly doesn't really help
with the appropriate case management of
these tv cases
however interestingly enough um you know
many of the same challenges have also
been experienced in other localities and
other geographies and these lessons
learned can be applied to different
contexts so for example in indonesia the
issue of you know parallel systems has
been fixed or
reduced by you know creating or merging
the drug resistant and drug susceptible
systems into one system
for example um you know in philippines
um the automation has has helped in
terms of um
helped with this intermediary excel step
so they've been able to automate that as
part of their current backbone system um
other validation features embedded in
for example in kenya's system
ensure that there is no
you know
bad or incomplete data and this is at
the point of entry so it certainly helps
with ensuring that everything that is
embedded in the platform is already
cleaned and verified um in india for
example patient duplication there's been
an intelligent transfer mechanism
embedded in their system and then lastly
you know in
in other countries but specifically in
indonesia they've addressed
interoperability by creating linkages
through apis or other such ways to
basically link the case-based system
with the aggregate reporting system or
other external tools
but technology alone is certainly not
enough
or sufficient for tv programs you know
the people aspects are just important
are just as important
challenges associated with
sufficient utilization of data and
appropriate use of the digital tools
have been seen
a big challenge here is the digital
literacy in a lot of these contexts
you know which prevents users from using
the the tools available they are more
familiar with their recognizable
paper-based workflows as opposed to what
they perceive as more difficult um you
know digital applications or digital um
tools available to them another big
aspect is having just the physical
infrastructure and resources available
as well as that motivation and behavior
change to address
some of the challenges with getting
people using these digital tools some
best practices have been used such as
using user-centric design
so basically suiting the technology to
the needs of the users or the healthcare
workers that use these technologies
ensuring that this is applied with their
usual workflows and so that technology
is not seen as an extra burden but
actually eases their day-to-day tasks
and then of course strong capacity and
training is required and necessary for
users to feel well equipped to use the
available technologies
in their in their countries
the last thing which i believe that's
the least amount of tension is you know
this interaction with the wider
ecosystem
this last theme you know touches on
partner coordination policy aspects
funding interaction with you know the
broader health system and most recently
the implications of the coven 19
pandemic
however an interesting and notable
observation as countries have kind of
evolved to these digital health systems
is the role of open source and private
propriety proprietary solutions uh
common concerns of proprietary solutions
are in regards to sustainability and the
need for ongoing funding to pay for
these ongoing ongoing maintenance of
private solutions so for example uh gx
alert and data2care are two diagnostic
connectivity solutions by two different
vendors um they have been you know
scaled to nearly 40 countries they
have been
studied in terms of impact um and have
been supported by a handful of countries
as their as their main tool or trusted
tool however across the 13 countries in
this study uh you know a few such as
three or more have used these systems
but have instead chosen to build their
own systems which leads to a replication
of work um this you know is an
implication to the global community um
and it's it's really an implication to
understand how do we support these
innovators uh to develop digital
solutions but also facilitate those
market dynamics for their sustained use
so there are just a few of the those are
just a few of the key recommendations
that come out of the study
that mapped these four components that i
described you know the the technical
building blocks the digital architecture
the interactions with people and
interactions with ecosystem but what the
study really found is that all of these
components are actually all interlinked
um you know you you cannot have adequate
use of the various different policies on
data hosting
if you don't have the technical building
blocks to support such an infrastructure
you also may be able to build the most
you know efficient and robust
and interoperable architecture digital
architecture but it may result to
nothing if you don't have the end users
to actually benefit from such a system
and actually have that uptake of the
system so these all are all very
interlinked and
need to be
used together
holistically so some of these
recommendations on the screen you know
there's there's these pricing concerns
there's the awareness of the local
infrastructure having those
user-centered approaches and having
strong policy guidance
all these themes are equally important
therefore working towards you know
having all these addressing these
cross-cutting themes
is required to certainly evolve to a
better digital health system
thank you very much for listening really
appreciate it
coming up next we have mandy hall and
kartik bhatt with a talk titled we are
almost doctors ourselves caregivers
roles in chronic disease care in india
hi i'm mandy hall
a ux health researcher on the medical
experiences and design team which is
part of the health futures group within
microsoft research
our design research mission is to gain
better insights
create better experiences accomplish
better care my team supports health
features teams by employing design
thinking to reimagine
and and improve the healthcare
experience for all with new technology i
am excited to introduce karthik who i
mentored this past summer
karthik was a microsoft research intern
engaging with tiffany cool and brooke
logan on the global health access team
in collaboration with colleagues
at microsoft research india
karthik is a fourth year phd student in
human-centered computing at georgia tech
his dissertation work examines
socioculturally situated personal
and intermediated technology use by
various stakeholders and chronic disease
care in india his recent research focus
has been on the uptake of telehealth for
non-emergent chronic disease care in
india
as a response to coven 19 induced
disruptions to the health care system
with its now increased usage his work
seeks to address emerging challenges to
the wider adoption of telehealth as a
viable solution to alleviate existing
burdens on the indian
healthcare system
karthik's talk will go into the personal
healthcare technology ecosystem in india
and provide takeaways for partners and
collaborators envisioning solutions in
this space i'll turn over to karthik
thank you
thanks for the introduction mandy uh
good evening everyone and thank you for
attending this talk
my name is karthik bhatt and i will be
talking about supporting caregiving
roles in chronic disease care in india
this talk draws heavily on my phd work
at georgia tech and motivates and
presents some of the work i did as a
research intern at microsoft research
health futures this past summer
i'm really excited to be sharing my
research with you and want for this
presentation to help uncover and unleash
new ideas for designing future
healthcare technologies
going into that of course requires a
quick overview of what healthcare
technologies for patients currently
looks like
so from an individual perspective focus
has mostly been on self-tracking
it looks like the smart watches that you
wear on your wrist and collect some
health data about you
it looks like medical devices like
lancer glucometers and blood pressure
monitors
that you use to collect physiological
health data
then it looks like data analysis and
visualization tools that take such data
and manipulates them in such a way that
it makes health sense-making easier
such devices and technologies are
becoming more prevalent which has made
health tracking more convenient and
pervasive
this is being leveraged increasingly in
chronic disease management among other
contacts because it allows patients to
participate more actively in their care
so that they can be better informed
about their health
now there are at least two trends that
stand out to us from exploring this
broad area of research and commercial
technologies
the first is an expectation of
technology availability literacy and
usage among the target user groups
the second is the expectation of
personal usage of these technologies
now both of these are fair assumptions
to make when when the research and
design is situated in the resource-rich
context of the global north where the
expectation is justified and the health
care system is focused on primarily
personal care provision
that made us wonder what happens when
you strip away these assumptions and
situate this care provision in a
cultural context that is far more
community oriented and where healthcare
has much stronger power imbalances
associated with them so we asked what
social cultural dimensions influence
health tracking and patient-centered
care
we conducted this study in urban india
interviewing doctors as well as patients
and their family members to understand
their health tracking behaviors
we drew on prior research that had
surfaced the the unique social cultural
dynamics of healthcare in india
now that isn't the focus of this talk
and i encourage you to read our csaw
paper from 2020.
pertinent to this talk however was our
findings around how all of these
activities like health tracking
information seeking and patient doctor
consultations
were leveraging patients family members
as caregivers both in clinical and home
settings
this led us down this line of research
well soon after the study the covert 19
pandemic hit and disrupted the
healthcare system in india just like it
did across the world
it changed the nature of these patient
doctor interactions that i had
previously studied and it also changed
the requirements for at home care
management
government lockdowns and overworked
healthcare infrastructures in response
to the pandemic meant that chronic
disease patients needed to find
alternative methods of consultations
with doctors that were consistent with
the covet safety protocols at the time
the solution that we found through a
survey and interview study was
telehealth
now it's important to note that
telehealth has had a presence in india
for many years
but given the social cultural dynamics
of healthcare in india it had always
been marginalized used mainly to provide
coverage to remote regions of the
country as a service between healthcare
providers as opposed to between patients
and providers directly
this was a crucial element of last mile
care delivery
but it did not receive the widespread
adoption that it initially promised
mainly because these expectations the
expectations from patient doctor
consultations involved the so-called
healing touch which essentially mandated
physical consultations
the pandemic then created an environment
where telehealth saw a resurgence it
became the main if not the only safe way
to to provide continuing care for
chronic disease patients
in this backdrop we asked how patients
and doctors were adapting to shifting
trends in healthcare provision in
response to the covert 19 pandemic
our findings go into great detail on the
different ways in which patients
caregivers doctors hospitals and
pharmacies leveraged existing
technologies
most importantly whatsapp that's a
widely used messaging platform in india
to allow for this healthcare provision
you can find these details and more in
our cscw paper which will be available
in october 2021
the takeaway from the study informing
our focus on caregivers
was that caregiver roles and
consultations were changing as
telehealth necessarily needed greater
technology literacy and proficiency
and family members and caregivers who
were more tech savvy were being looped
into a patient's consultation experience
more and more so finally this summer we
focused directly on caregivers in the
age of telehealth
from prior studies we had the knowledge
that caregivers played some role in
patients chronic disease care
they were leveraging the personal health
technologies on behalf of their loved
ones and they were involved in patient
doctor interactions to ensure timely and
effective care for their loved ones
at microsoft research we want to
understand where and how specifically
caregivers played a role in this chronic
disease care and questioned whether they
could be the benefactors of
interventions and solutions aimed at
reducing barriers to healthcare access
and healthcare infrastructure navigation
and medication adherence in india
this was specif this was specifically
our focus because a major barrier to
healthcare access in india stems from
infrastructural constraints
easy access to quality care affordable
care and so on uh were persistent
problems across the country
we started off considering how best to
target telehealth solutions to these
patients so that its remote nature could
overcome some of these infrastructural
barriers
then we pivoted drawing on my prior work
to instead center caregivers in our
analysis would that lead to more unique
exciting and actionable findings
so we asked how involved are caregivers
in their loved ones care and how can
they be better served by technology
to answer this question we conducted 20
interviews with caregivers caring for a
range of chronic conditions like type 2
diabetes cardiac diseases pulmonary
diseases and arthritis
we asked about what their caregiving
responsibilities were
what their involvement and consultations
were and how much agency they had in
taking health decisions for themselves
and their loved ones
now our findings from the study are
still under peer review so if you'd like
to read a preprint please contact me my
contact details are available online or
at the end of this presentation
our main takeaways from this funding
from the study were solution spaces for
future technologies we identified
problems that caregivers had while
intermediating their loved ones care in
the indian healthcare context
we then went on to propose how
addressing these problems could actually
greatly improve care outcomes for their
loved ones
for example we propose that camera-based
technologies that leverage
state-of-the-art advances in image
processing in mixed reality could assist
caregivers in their tasks effectively
improving their loved ones quality of
life
where we found problems in supporting
telehealth we proposed educational
material for caregivers to be more
effective to help them be more effective
in their roles uh
during teleconsultations
finally a mechanism for caregivers to
coordinate care tasks among themselves
could result in more efficient care
delivery to their loved ones
in this way we found direct actionable
insights into how caregivers could be
empowered to improve health health
outcomes for their loved ones
more details can be found in the paper
or in the preprint of the paper
the overarching argument of the study
was that in order to address problems of
delayed access to care of lapsing out of
medication adherence and of the
difficulties navigating overburdened
healthcare systems
caregivers not only place some
supporting role but actually play
crucial and instrumental roles in access
to care
our food for thought to other product
teams and researchers interested in this
space
is
imagine stepping back from targeting
solutions at patients directly
what if instead you're designed for
caregivers who are likely more tech
savvy so that they leverage these
solutions to access better quality care
for their loved ones
that's my talk a huge shout out to my
wonderful mentors at microsoft mandy
hall and tiffany quo
and
the teams that i was a part of this past
summer
the global health access team and
medical experiences design team and the
several other microsoft research
researchers that i spoke to during the
course of these uh three months as i
designed the study and actually like
went through this experience as an
intern thank you so much for attending
this talk and please reach out to me if
you'd like to talk more about my work
for collaborations or for just the the
papers that are still in in press
now we go to vanessa and rich for their
talk
hi i'm rich carwana
and i'm vanessa polk
and we're going to talk about using
interpretable machine learning to better
understand health and health care
inequities
there are many kinds of bias in health
care and health care data an
intelligible machine learning is one of
the tools we can use to detect this bias
and better understand it
this is how intelligible machine
learning works for every feature such as
age or asthma we have a graph
and the way the graphs work is you look
up the patient's age on the x-axis and
then you read off the contribution to
risk on the vertical axis
and that gives us a number the larger
the number the more it increases risk
and the smaller the number the more risk
goes down
so we might have 50 features that would
give us 50 numbers and then we just do a
sum of all those numbers and that gives
us an overall risk score for the patient
again the larger that score the larger
the risk for the patient
and this kind of model is interpretable
because we can understand each of the
graphs for each feature and we can
understand exactly how the model makes
predictions
this is a graph of risk as a function of
age when predicting pneumonia mortality
and what the model has learned is that
being young is low risk remember low is
low risk
it's not too bad to be in your fifties
and sixties
risk goes up pretty quickly when you go
into retirement we often see that in
health care data in the united states
then risk rises
rises rapidly as you go through your 70s
into your 80s
and then there's a surprising rapid rise
in risk right around 85.
risk is surprisingly flat in the upper
80s and 90s
and then an even more surprising drop in
risk over a hundred
the rise in risk at 85 and the drop at
risk at 100 are both age biases
what happens is that doctors consider
patients over 85 to be very elderly and
because of that these patients sometimes
receive less aggressive treatment and
that can elevate their risk
the opposite thing is happening at a
hundred here the patients have made it
to being 100 their centenarians and the
doctors don't want centenarians to die
in their watch they kind of want to go
for the record and because of this they
give even more aggressive treatment to
these patients and the model has
recognized that that treatment is
effective and lowers their risk
now this is risk as a function of age
for covid19 another respiratory illness
and there are a lot of similarities
between this graph and the graph we were
just looking at for pneumonia notice for
example that risk is pretty flat and low
for patients in their 20s 30s 40s and
50s and then we see rises in risk for
example a rise in risk at retirement age
and a rise in risk at age 85.
but one of the surprising differences is
that instead of seeing a drop in risk at
age 100 we see a big rise in risk at age
95.
and the reason why this is happening for
covid19 is many of the patients over age
95 are on do not intubate orders
intubation is a very risky procedure for
elderly patients and because they're on
do not intubate orders they're at higher
risk
so this is a form of age bias but it
might be a medically appropriate bias
this is risk
for a cancer data set as a function of
age and we see things that we expect
which is that the younger patients are
lower risk and then risk goes up as you
go through your 60s and into your 70s
what's surprising in this data set is
this drop in risk that's happening just
above age 75 so what's causing that
we believe this is a selection bias so
to be in this study patients were
supposed to be 75 or younger
or if they were over 75 they had to be
very very healthy and this had to be the
best treatment for their cancer
so what the model is recognizing is that
the patients over 75 seem to be a lower
risk group
probably because they're very healthy
patients
now this is a different kind of bias
that we see in the pneumonia data this
is a risk as a function of your blood
urea nitrogen this is a blood test all
of us have received and what we see is
the benefit of treatments for these
patients
so notice that risk goes up and then
flattens right around 50 when doctors
start to give a medication at 50 and
then risk continues to go up and
actually comes down a little bit past a
hundred dialysis has started to be given
to the patients above a hundred so we're
seeing the benefits of treatments in the
graph
but it's interesting
is 50 and 100 really the optimum
treatment threshold there really is a
sort of round number bias here using
these 50s and 100 doctors use round
numbers because it makes it easier to
work with these policies but in fact
patients are quite high risk already by
35 or 40 and maybe should be given the
med earlier and similarly patients are
pretty high risk uh at 85 or 90 and
maybe dialysis should be given earlier
we see these sort of round number
effects all over in healthcare data so
this is systolic blood pressure and
notice that risk goes up around 175 then
comes down as blood pressure gets higher
goes up again around 200 and then comes
down again goes up around 225 and then
comes down again it is not the case that
having your blood pressure get higher
will make your risk lower what we're
seeing is that patients are hitting
different treatment thresholds for
example maybe getting higher doses of
meds and those treatments are effective
and lower the risk for the patients
now let me talk about some kind of bias
that we see in pregnancy and maternal
morbidity data severe maternal morbidity
is when we're trying to predict that the
mother has a bad outcome during labor
and if we ask doctors what are the key
factors for predicting risk for the
mother during labor they'll say things
like maternal hypertension maternal
diabetes maternal obesity
now these are all factors that describe
the mother because we're trying to
predict the race of the mother this is a
kind of confirmation bias the doctors
are giving us description of features
for the mother because we're trying to
predict the risk for the mother
but when we throw an interpretable model
at this data the story is completely
different the model tells us that the
single most important factor is the size
of the baby
if the baby is large then the mother is
at higher risk during labor
the second most important factor is the
size of the mother if the mother is
small then the mother is at higher risk
basically the model is telling us it's
the physics of birth that matter most
for maternal risk
and this led us to create a feature
which is a bmi for pregnancy we define
it as the baby's birth weight divided by
the mother's height squared height is
the best estimate we have of mother
frame size in this data set
and if we create this feature it
immediately becomes the single most
important feature for predicting risk
for the mother during labor
but there's other kinds of bias we see
in this pregnancy data we see
socioeconomic bias
so this is a graph of risk to the mother
during labor as a function of the
poverty rate of the region from which
the mother comes from and you can see
for low to medium poverty rate risk is
essentially low and flat but as the
poverty rate increases the risk to the
mother increases
this is a really interesting feature it
measures how close the mother lives to
the hospital that will provide the the
care during pregnancy if you're in an
urban setting you're on the left of this
graph and at lowest risk and as you go
to more rural settings you're on the
right side of the graph and you
typically live further away from the
hospital and notice that risk sort of
increases monotonically as you go from
an urban setting
to a more rural setting
so now we don't know exactly how to
explain this one possibility is that
it's the time it takes to get from home
to the hospital once you go into labor
that counts and that just takes longer
if you're in a rural setting
it's possible that there's a
socio-economic factor here maybe urban
settings are wealthier uh than rural
settings or it's possible that the
quality of care given in large uh urban
hospitals is better than the overall
quality of care being given at smaller
smaller rural rural hospitals we don't
really know what the right explanation
is for this
now this is race as a function of
ethnicity
and notice that the graph is sort of
flat for most ethnicities so that's good
we do have high risk on the left this is
when we're missing the ethnicity we
don't know why we have high risk for
this group perhaps things were going so
bad and so quickly that there wasn't
time to record an ethnicity
and on the right we see that for whites
we see a reduction in risk so that's
unfortunate
you might ask well why are we not seeing
elevated risk for groups where we would
expect it say blacks
or for pacific islanders and one
explanation is that this model has
access to the socioeconomic and
demographic features that i showed you
in the previous graphs and maybe once it
accounts for risk using those features
it no longer sees a difference due to
race
but let's look at a cancer data set here
we see a different story here we do see
that whites are at lower risk and blacks
are at elevated risk and then there's
this other category which we don't
understand very well at this point which
is at the highest risk now you might ask
well why in this data set are we seeing
a difference between whites and blacks
that we didn't see in the previous data
set
well it turns out in this cancer data
set we don't have access to
socioeconomic and demographic variables
so maybe what the model is doing is it's
doing its best to learn socioeconomic
demographic effects but it's doing that
through the only correlated feature it
has the ethnicity of the mother
let me end by talking about covid19
mortality
so we've all heard that men were at
higher risk of dying than women from
covid19 and the model definitely learns
this this is a large discrepancy
now we don't think that this is any sort
of gender bias in the care of the
patients uh what we think is happening
here is that most of the people who die
from covid19 are elderly and it is
widely accepted that men are more frail
when they're elderly than women so a 75
year old man is typically considered to
be at higher risk from a respiratory
illness than a woman who's 75 years old
and we believe that's what the model is
learning so think of this as being a
sort of true biological risk as opposed
to some sort of health care bias
now this is looking at covid19 risk as a
function of race and notice that blacks
are the lowest risk group and whites are
the highest risk group so that's
interesting now this graph is when we
don't account for any of the other risk
factors such as comorbidities or age or
gender of the patient
if we take the other factors into
account the story changes a little bit
for example whites are now lower risk
and and blacks are higher risk and some
other groups such as hispanics and this
other category are now equally high or
higher risk than whites
but we still have the overall picture
that blacks are lower risk than whites
so what might explain this in the data
well as we dive in deeper and look at
the data more carefully we find the
following it turns out the typical age
of whites in the hospital with covid19
is significantly larger than the age for
blacks in the hospital with covid19 this
is a discrepancy of about 20 years here
so what would explain that sort of
difference well there's multiple
possibilities here one is that the life
expectancy for black males in the u.s is
significantly less than the white
expectancy for white males in the u.s so
maybe this just represents demographics
another possibility is that blacks might
be more front-line workers so perhaps
they are getting covid19 and thus having
to be admitted to the hospital when
they're younger age 60 and still working
whereas the whites might not be getting
this as front line workers maybe they're
working more from home and what we're
seeing is more whites are getting
covered 19 and admitted to the hospital
in elder care facilities
another possibility is that blacks might
live in higher density housing so
they're more likely to get covid19 from
their family whereas it's possible that
whites are more likely to get covered 19
again in high density elder care
facilities we don't really know what the
proper explanation it is for the
discrepancies we see between risk for
blacks and whites but these are some of
the possibilities
so let me wrap up there are many kinds
of bias that we see in healthcare and
healthcare data and things get
complicated very quickly and sometimes
intelligibility is just showing us the
tip of the iceberg and you really have
to go diving to figure out what's going
on
the importance of machine learning
especially intelligible machine learning
for equity is because intelligibility
helps you detect bias that maybe you
didn't expect in the first place such as
selection bias
it also then helps you try to understand
that bias and what the true source is
so now i'm going to hand things over to
vanessa
thank you rich
there are a lot of questions around
health equity and how demographics
affect health outcomes
when a difference exists between groups
when is it medically reasonable or
something due to let's say genetic and
when is it a signal that something
problematic is at play something that
might need to be explored or may require
some sort of intervention or proactivity
we have to know why
as you can see here there's been an
uptick in clinical research around the
use of race in clinical protocols and
decision making
unfortunately what a lot of this
research has found is that this
particular use of race has often led to
the under treatment of certain groups
particularly black patients
as health systems turn to ai machine
learning and other advanced analytic
methods these models are learning from
these outdated protocols in addition to
other things such as social bias that
exists in our society still today
this is why it is so important to use
intelligible models
via the use of interpretable learning
methods we can uncover why these models
are learning what they do and what's
actually driving some of the differences
we see and that rich so eloquently
outlined earlier
allowing these models to learn without
transparency risks propagating existing
protocols and practices that may not be
good things that might be continuing to
cost human life and outcomes
the promise of these intelligible
learning methods for health equity is
that they enable us to truly learn why
we're seeing the differences that we do
and what might require intervention what
might not require an intervention at all
and where we can best intervene when
appropriate
so with that said we would like to thank
you for coming to this talk today and
please
really consider the use of intelligible
learning methods in discussions of
health equity and population health
thank you